there is an Indian YouTube channel on
the brink of becoming girls number one
it's taken us lot of effort to come this
far to take my father mr. Christian
Kumar's dream forward I started this
channel today it belongs to you it
belongs to the entire nation this is a
historic moment for all of us so let's
come together and subscribe to t-series
YouTube channel and make India proud
hashtag convince YouTube well well well
we're getting a little bit desperate are
we t-series you know what I smell I
smell fear you're scared and you have
every right to be scared because I am
NOT just some ordinary youtuber
understand everyone in the comments grab
gay crap okay great
okay this is what you were up against
t-series I hope you understand that you
have absolutely no chance of survival
[Music]
Greg Dean great okay great okay come
here come here
oh look at you you're so cute don't be
scared come to poppy no no yep oh my god
I'm so sorry
grab tea sometimes killed by accident
that's how strong I am
alright you come here
I don't like how you guys I'm legs
give me the leg thanks Friday these are
my legs now go away
Jesus Christ grab dude ah stop it stop
fighting what the hell is he doing
stop trying to taunt the scribe King
come walk to poppy you can do it come to
crab game nope damn it I don't want to
kill him
yeah yeah this is what happens to all
who oppose crab king something what when
you're like stop moving your leg there
you go
pray ding oh you want your legs back
here come get your leg it's right there
you can do it you're almost there you're
touching it yeah you have your leg now
come to grab King for a little hug
Oh No Oh No let me grab them you fools
you legless bastard you have nothing
nothing what is this another leg
delicious
no nom nom nom nom let's kick you in the
face
hmm this is what I do with legs ah pick
your nipple huh are you gonna stop with
the legs that's what I thought now give
me those but once a free snack there you
go
oh no no no no no he loves it that was a
gift oh yeah baby
no no turn around for me baby oops sorry
we can still harvest we can still use
them it's called recycling don't do it
don't tell them I don't care you foot
like Felix the prophecy said you have to
befriend the feet I don't care
get him foot I don't wanna hurt them
shut up foot get him keep your face
you're in the face because I don't like
you
crab King does not like my legs anymore
more legs there's so many legs to
capture there's so many I helped know
what by myself can i jumble with them I
wonder if I can
well I can't I totally can wait let me
just read it I need one that's alive
there you go you're alive right yeah I'm
fine right it's a little hard to throw
oh look they have chips now how
possiblys crab can go to defeat this Oh
No
please go easy on me guys please oh
what's that yours I'm so sorry
have it back they have freaking hammers
where did you find that here give me
that give me the hammer
give me the hammer he made the ham game
800 I said give me hammer god damn this
guy's strong let it go thank you
it's my hammer okay you understand oh no
stop stop stop I had enough don't come
near me cracking very dangerous Jesus
Christ stop don't come near me
whoopsie what am i hammer go I won't
have bosses on me and I should go back
giant mode what is a giant mode I
thought I was already pretty big boss
rush old truck okay now we have some
stuff oh wow okay so that nut salute Hey
which weapon am I going to pick I think
the harpoon crab Kings hands are too big
he cannot grab please I just want to
grab okay fine I'll go with that please
alright I guess it's you
if you and me buddy crab crab crab crab
crab crab crab crab crab hey how you
doing
don't hurt me please what did I say huh
what did I say you stupid idiot
I dunno why no you're gonna have to
cover your legs what is this nah
stop attack your nicing mate stop
how would you still moving oh god it's
the beaver guy oh god I don't have time
for you please get that beavers there's
enough beavers Felix aha
they went for my face cracking don't
hurt cracking I'm a friend of the
animals got you now beaver could ya come
here
I died from beaver god dammit I know
it's not a beaver
okay you can stop what's your name look
at you whoa it's free good jump they're
crazy
stop it stop get the foot I wanna get
the pain I spare your life in exchange
for your feet those are the rules of the
crab King now thanked crab king what are
you tryin tack he's trying to fight back
too bad you have no chance
please Phoenix will subscribe not good
enough I don't care I'm the one with the
power
Oh crab cake crab cake knows some moves
Oh oh god it's didn't beavers again
don't don't I got a sword please I don't
want to hurt your beavers I'm gonna have
to clean off their legs that's it
nice and smooth we're gonna have to
amputate ah it's got my face it's on my
face
stop John beaver get up get off Krakens
only weightless Jesus Christ stop oh oh
thank god oh thank god okay gonna jump
he's gonna jump and he shields
oh yeah oh yeah you're scared aren't you
come here come here come on come on then
what the hell did he do that question oh
sorry I didn't mean to crush your face
oh god no no no no get out away from me
get it away from me that oh thank god
maybe I'm a little too overpowered here
maybe makes it roll too easy so let's
tone it down just a little bit oh wow
I'm your weapon and salute I am a very
small crab I can't I can't reach the
hose ah I got them oh crap king crab
cake pancakes ready [ __ ] thank you
alright we know how to do this go for
the knees but first attack
ah hey Tory's ass in hair oh my God he's
giant how could I possibly fight back
got him
super strength crap we got his knee
packs is these are explose I any media
feed huh still alive look at me look at
me look at me look at me when I'm
talking to you no oh god they're giant
now
[Applause]
how is that possible
ah but my my crab cranes think it goes
happening I'm losing my heart
no no went backwards got a retreat the
battle is lost but not that we build war
Oh God
I really think you can make it let's go
race right thing ha ha ha
crank things right whoa oh oh god oh god
I'm not gonna make it huh huh Oh almost
there huh oh there's our crab strength
grabbed a snap but one day Franklin
returned to burst simulator it's now so
relevant that it's got a brand new
minigame crania drop the crane and get
fresh items only available in the
washing machine like game and you say
there's more of course there is new
knowledge perks new quests and new picks
links and legs guys leg